is there something else that jumps to
mind like
what is there something um i know like
in terms of papers like i know the
bitcoin paper is super popular
is there something interesting to be
said about any of the white papers
in the cryptocurrency space yeah the the
the bitcoin paper was the first paper
that we put on for mods
and uh why why that why that choice
as the first paper this was a while ago
and it was
one of the papers that i read and then
uh
and then kind of explained it to to
louisiana or two other friends that do
this journal club with us
and um i did some research in
cryptography
as an undergrad and so it was a topic
that i was interested in
um but even for me that i i had that
background but
reading the bitcoin paper it took me a
few weeks to really kind of wrap my head
around it
it's it's right it's it uses very
spartan precise language in a way
it's like you feel like you can't take
any word out of it without
something falling apart and uh and it's
all there i think it's a beautiful
paper and it's it's it's very
well written of course but um
you know we wanted to try to make it
accessible so that anybody that
maybe is an undergrad in computer
science could go on there
and then and and know that you have all
the information
in in that page that you're going to
need to understand the mechanics of
bitcoin
and so like i explain you know the basic
uh public key cryptography that you need
to
to know in order to understand it like
you can explain okay what are the
properties of a hash function
and how they are useful in this context
um
explain what a merkle tree is so a bunch
of those basic concepts that maybe if
you're reading it for a first time and
you're an undergrad and you know
you don't know those terms you're going
to be you know discouraged because maybe
okay now i have to go and google around
until i understand these before i can
make progress in the paper um and and
this way it's all there
you know so so there's a magic to also
to the fact that
over time more people went on there and
and added further annotations so the
idea that the paper gets easier and more
accessible
over time but that's still you're still
looking at the original
content the way the the author intended
it to be
but there's just more context and the
toughest bits have
have more in-depth explanations
you